you
in today's morning rounds how age can
affect your body's response to seasonal
allergies more than 50 million Americans
have had allergies at some point in
their lives symptoms can change as you
grow older this morning almost one third
of the country is dealing with medium to
high levels of pollen our doctor Tara
Narula is here with how you can cope
good morning we're not cold morning so
age impacts seasonal allergies huh well
as I get older what's gonna happen to me
well we're learning that there is an
interaction between age and allergies
and so while you can develop allergies
at any age there are really two kind of
Peaks the first being in early childhood
so kind of elementary school years and
then the second and early adulthood but
once you get over 60 and I don't know if
you're over 60 chador system starts to
decline and so you're less likely
develop allergies more likely to get
infections so there are other things
that can change during you know age that
can affect allergies things like
hormones so for instance younger boys
tend to have more allergies as they hit
puberty they kind of outgrow them
whereas girls seem to develop more
allergies in adolescence what's a
connection between allergies and
hormones we're not sure but we do think
that estrogen has some role in kind of
the histamine interaction and histamine
we know is what is part of the allergic
reaction cycle
in addition environment can change so
you can move from one area to another
that contributor trigger your allergies
and some people say how did I get
allergies in my adulthood I never had
them as a kid well maybe you have them
as a kid and you didn't know or they
weren't diagnosed the best way to really
tell is to get to an allergist and have
either a skin test or a blood test to
really definitively tell you if you have
allergies yeah so this happened in are
now is the question is it allergies or
is it just a cold however the tell-tale
sign a lot of parents can struggle with
that because there can be similarity so
first it's rare to develop allergies if
you're under two seasonal allergies as a
child second you want to look at
duration are the symptoms lasting a
couple days more likely a cold or weeks
to months more likely allergies track
them do they happen at the same time
every year or your kid is okay in the
house and then the minute they go
outside they suddenly start coughing or
sneezing in addition if there's fever
more likely to be a cold you can look at
the the secretions if the mucus is clear
or watery it's more like
allergies and importantly if your child
complains a lot of itching itching eyes
that she knows that really tends to be
more of a hallmark of allergies kids can
also have like lack of sleep fatigue
trouble at school so what can you do to
avoid some of the most intense allergic
reactions well the best thing to do is
to start early so you want to prep you
know and start taking your medications
two weeks before allergy season starting
it before yes two weeks before before
your body starts to create this reaction
there are nasal steroids which are
really the first line of treatment
there's also other drugs antihistamines
you can get allergy shots immunotherapy
but you can work with an allergist to
create a plan and then there's practical
things so close your windows use your
air conditioner or make sure that you
wash your clothes your hair your body
after you come inside bathe regularly
yes bathe regularly it's a good idea
right hygiene very important lay your
sunglasses wear a hat so there are a lot
of practical things that you can do to
help alright right dr. teri thank you